إذا كنت قد سمعت أي شيء مؤخرًا عن
الاختبارات ، فهذا يعني أننا لم نقم بإجراء عدد
كافٍ منها في الولايات المتحدة
اليوم ، يركز الجميع بشدة على إجراء
الاختبار ، فقد فاتهم النقطة التي مفادها أن
الاختبار السيئ أسوأ من عدم وجود اختبار وقد
يكون ذلك أكثر من ذلك.  المشكلة الأساسية
هي مدى جودة الاختبارات في المقام الأول
، أنشأت إدارة الغذاء والدواء (FDA) أساسًا
بيئة الغرب المتوحش لهذا الاختبار ،
حيث سمحوا بموجب عملية الموافقة الخاصة بهم في
حالات الطوارئ بإجراء اختبارات في
السوق لها نطاق واسع جدًا بشكل أساسي
من النتائج مايكل أوسترهولم
هو مدير مركز
أبحاث وسياسات الأمراض المعدية في
جامعة مينيسوتا ،
تختلف جودة هذه الاختبارات في الوقت الحالي بشكل
كبير وهذا تحد من حيث
الفهم إذا حصلت على نتيجة سلبية ،
فهل هي سلبية حقًا
يمكن أن يحدد اختبار التشخيص الجزيئي ما إذا كان
لديك فيروس فعلي بداخلك عن طريق
سحب عينة من البلعوم الأنفي
أو من اللعاب عن طريق البصق في
قنينة.  مثلما فعلت ثم اختبرته بحثًا عن
الآثار الجينية للفيروس ، فإن مدى نجاح
الاختبارات في العثور على هذه العلامات الجينية
يُعرف بالحساسية إذا كان الاختبار يحتوي على
حساسية ضعيفة ، فسيؤدي ذلك إلى الكثير من
النتائج السلبية الخاطئة مما يعني أن
الكثير من الأشخاص يختبرون نتائج سلبية بالنسبة لـ
عندما يصابوا بالفيروس فعليًا ، أجرينا
دراسة حيث نظرنا في
أكثر من 200 عينة واختبرناها
بالطريقة الخمسة جميعها وهناك
اختلافات بين هذه الاختبارات د.  يعمل Gary
Pro cough رئيس قسم علم الفيروسات في
عيادة Cleveland Clinic
، وقد وجد وفريقه ثلاثة اختبارات
تحتوي على حساسية تزيد عن 95٪ من
اختبار CDC Cepheid and Roche مما يعني أنهم
اكتشفوا جميع الحالات تقريبًا باستثناء 5٪ ،
لكن معرف أبوت المشهور جدًا يختبر الآن
والتي يمكن أن تعطي نتائج في دقائق فقد
ما يصل إلى 15٪ من المرضى المصابين ،
وجدت دراسة أخرى أنه من المحتمل أن يكون قد فات
25٪ من العدوى وهذا مصدر قلق
لأنه على الرغم من نتائج الاختبارات السلبية ، فإن
هؤلاء الأشخاص مصابون بالفعل
ويمكنهم نشر الفيروس
الذي لن تريده أبدًا  لاستخدام هذا الاختبار
لفحص شخص ما في المستشفى
لوضعه في وحدة رمز
سلبي لأنه في هذه الحالة
لا يمكنك تحمل ارتكاب خطأ في
بيان قال أبوت إن نوع
وسائط النقل الفيروسي التي تستخدم
في نقل الفيروس  يمكن أن تكون العينة
مخففة للعينات التي اتصلنا بها على الفور
مع عملائنا بأنه
يجب عليهم استخدام طريقة المسحة المباشرة
، ولا تزال نتائج دراسة السعال المؤيدة
لمراجعة الأقران
عندما سئل عما إذا كان قد تم التضحية بالدقة
على حساب السرعة ، قال متحدث باسم إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية
لشبكة سي إن إن إن إشراف إدارة الغذاء والدواء الأمريكية لا ينتهي
بتصريح من الاتحاد الأوروبي أو استخدام طارئ ،
سنستمر في تتبع هذه الاختبارات
واتخاذ الإجراءات إذا لزم الأمر
حتى في منتصف الوباء
لا يزال يتعين على الأشخاص إعادة فاتورة متجر البقالة
تعتبر أعمالًا أساسية
الآن ، والحكمة التقليدية
هي تحديد عدد الرحلات إلى
متجر البقالة التي يمكن أن تكون صعبة
ولا يمكنك شراء كل شيء مرة واحدة أو
ليس لديك مساحة كافية في منزلك  منزل
لتخزين كل شيء ، لذا أريد أن أوضح لك
اليوم كيفية القيام بذلك بأمان قدر
الإمكان ، فهو يخطط للمستقبل ، لقد حصلت على قائمتي ،
إنها تتحرك بكفاءة عبر
المتجر وتفكر في كل سطح
قد تلمسه ولا تريد التخلص منه
فكر في نفسك نوعًا ما مثل أحد
أعضاء فريق SWAT ، احصل على القليل
من التتبع لنفسك قدر الإمكان ، دعنا نذهب
للقيام بذلك الآن ضع في اعتبارك الاستمتاع
بهذه الأشياء حول سلامتك
الخاصة وهي حقيقة.  حول سلامة
عمال الخطوط الأمامية ، سأدخل
وأخرج بسرعة كبيرة ولكن عمال الخطوط الأمامية
موجودون هنا طوال اليوم لذا فهم
أكثر خطورة وأعتقد أنه من الجيد بخصوص
هذه القصة بالذات أن
ريتشارد هنا يمسح جميع الأسطح
شكرًا لك ،
نعم ، أحمل معقم يدي
يعمل فقط في حالة ما إذا كان بإمكاني أن
أخبرك أننا نعيش هنا في متجر البقالة
ويحتفظون بساعات خاصة أن الأشخاص
المعرضين للخطر طبيًا في الساعة 7:00
صباحًا
أراد أطفالي القدوم حقًا
لقد أرادوا معي اليوم الخروج من
المنزل ولكن التسوق في الوقت الحاضر هو
نشاط فردي إلى حد كبير
وتذكر عدم لمس أي شيء
لن تشتريه ، فأنا شديد
التركيز
[موسيقى]
لدي  الأطفال
[الموسيقى] ،
فهذه هي الطريقة التي يقومون بها في محل بقالة ،
يرجى الانتظار هنا مما يبقيك على بعد
ستة أقدام من الأشخاص ،
ما نراه في الوقت الحالي هو
توسيع طريقة العناية المركزة إلى ما وراء
الحدود التقليدية
للمساحة المادية التي  العناية المركزة ط  نحن
نعتني بأننا نعتني بمرضى co19 يزداد حجمهم
وأكبر في الوقت الذي
نعتني فيه بمرضى مصابين بأمراض خطيرة سيحتاجون إلى
مساحة سرير تتسع لكل
من سرير المريض نفسه ولكن
أيضًا حول الأجهزة  التي
تساهم في معدات دعم الحياة
التي لدينا في وحدات العناية المركزة
مقسمة حقًا إلى فئتين ،
الأولى هي ميل آلات دعم الحياة
لتكون مثالًا رائعًا ،
التحدي الرئيسي الذي نجده في
المرضى الذين يعانون من جبل كبير هو
الضرر  إنه يؤثر على الرئة
ويختفي أنه يخرج من
أجهزة دعم الكلى للطلاب وتضع مجموعة من
الكلى للفترة الزمنية التي
يستغرقها المريض لاستعادة أي عقاقير
صامتة في إطار خاص تأتي إلى
اللجنة عندما يمرض المرضى حقًا
يمكنك الحصول على آلة تأخذها  عبر
المضخة من خلال الأقسام ،
لن يقوم بعض هؤلاء أيضًا بنقل الأكسجين إلى
الدم ولكن يساعد في ضخ الدم
ثم النوع الثاني من Equi
لدينا أجهزة المراقبة الخاصة بنا ، لذا
فقد تبحث في التتبع الكهربائي
لضغط الدم في القلب ولدينا أيضًا أجهزة
لقياس مستوى الأكسجين في الدم ،
لذلك هناك الكثير من التقنيات باهظة الثمن
التي نبحث عنها الآلاف إن
لم يكن عشرات  بآلاف الجنيهات ، كل تلك
الموارد تركز على فرد واحد
لدينا عدد كبير بشكل ملحوظ من
الممرضات لدعم نشاط ما ، لذا فإن
مستشفانا الذي يحتوي على الأرجح على أسرة
تضم أكثر من 10000 جنيهات ، كان من
المدهش أن نرى كيف ارتقى الناس
إلى مستوى التحدي الذي نواجهه  من المحتمل أن يكون
لديك القدرة على شهور ولا حتى سنوات
للأنظمة الصحية الموازية ، أحدها
يتعامل مع الكابلات ولكن
الآخر يحاول إعادة إنشاء
الأسباب التي تجعلنا نركز حقًا على
النظر إلى الموظفين والتأكد من
قدرتهم على الاستمرار  لتقديم الخدمة من الآن
فصاعدًا من خلال التشفير وما
بعده
[الموسيقى]